this article is supposed to be about  what happens the day after tomorrow but  all i keep thinking about is what's  gonna happen the morning after  you know when barry's not in the kitchen  dancing while he's making breakfast  when i go back to work and there's no  surprise love letters zooped on my desk  while i type  and then i think  [Music]  i said goodbye to him before  but there's no getting him back from  this you know  [Music]  i mean this isn't just a story dad  i'm writing bears  i'm practicing how to say goodbye to him  and  [Music]  i don't know it just makes me doubt  everything  i mean what am i supposed to do  [Music]  you're married to the flesh so of course  it's gonna be hard to write a story  about him dying but i need you  to write this as if he always  lives  you